jg une surprise de ouf pour toi c'est
vrai alors j'en ai une première et une
deuxième lame et regarde y'a une amie
j'ai une très grande amie dans le
showbiz quelqu'un avec qui on est comme
ça je vous cache pas que non il ya eu il
ya pas eu de balle du tout mais vous
êtes sac à main c'est de l'amitié
oui mais non c'est de l'amitié qui n'est
pas là dedans la au bénin vient le tour
des centres 2 1 022 bull est là alors
s'agit d'une star internationale à blanc
que tu connais aussi son prénom ses
ébats oh non sonore csfa mendes et
longoria et oui mais les rats longoria
avait chanté pour elle une fois une ou
deux trois fois où je sais rien c'est
d'ailleurs dans un des tubes cool parce
que j'utilise tes paroles si j'aimerais
beaucoup que même la longue balle en
baisse à capter et bats toi tu regardes
tu es une faute ou d'ailleurs non c'est
encore j'adore ça c'est pas classe à moi
j'ai une photo avec essien isabelle
duval de ma classe de 5e c est donc vous
lui avez chanté une sérénade et vous
aviez aussi chanté pour elle sur votre
tube bella regarder et après on a une
petite surprise pour vous
[Musique]
et bien kenji [ __ ] et bacon bieber j'ai
appelé eva longoria alors et sans
numéros aux numéros d'eva longoria
il a rien de bien et ba et ba a envoyé
un petit message pour quoi comprendre
à signaler la place jean gros bisous à
tous mes matches
gros bisous
alors la vengeance dans la peau
j'ai une surprise pour vous sachez qu'il
ya sur twitter on va donner le hashtag
tout de suite maniez bull qui tout est
expliqué sur twitter vous allez sur le
site vous allez sur le poulet et arrêter
toute première embellie suppléera
massacre sur le compte twitter de tpm
paix vous d'y aller et il y à un dîner
en compagnie en présente les vallons
gorria le 18 mai au à cannes et j'y
serai également à n'ont à aucun moment
nous et non vers vous j'y serai
également merci alors franchement à
lisier inscrits ou sur twitter et il y
aura tirage au sort
je pense que kenji sera avec moi
j'espère bien entendu puisque tu sais
qu'à partir d'aujourd'hui on se lâche
plus cadjee est ce que tu peux nous
faire franchement parce que c'est une de
mes chansons préférées en plus auprès
d'aso c'est je vais mettre en position
position qui fâchent d'essorage on y va
tout s'en aller
baba au rhum
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa différence énorme c'est pas la même
parole si j'aimerais la chaise haute et
d'un soir ça va être compliqué alors
très vite commencé petit à petit le
soliste qu'a fait le nécessaire c'est
bon t'as fait le boulot en fait le
boulot